tapis oreiller cheveux herbe incorrect 165
volts choc fort je suis Stanley Milgram
et ceci est une expérience s'il vous plaît allez
vérifier que tout va bien continuez s'il vous plaît
prêt à obtenir de vraies réactions des
gens les expériences sur l'obéissance aux
ordres vous pourriez être mort là-dedans s'il vous
plaît continuer les relations sociales ce qui
fait  cela signifie tout, de la façon dont les
gens parlent des ascenseurs à l'étude du
formatage L'autorité en tant qu'êtres humains
anticipe les actes inhumains destructeurs
pourquoi le défi est-il l'anomalie au lieu de
la norme pourquoi ai-je arrêté parce qu'il m'a dit
de continuer tu te dis pourquoi n'ai-
je pas un  choix je ne ferais pas ça
tu l'as fait je ne ferais jamais ça je
n'aime blesser personne cette partie avec son
Batman commence vraiment
la transformation de ton père en un personnage fictif les
critiques insistent sur ton insensibilité
contraire à l'éthique trompeuse personne le public
n'a été forcé  vous êtes investi dans l'idée
d'autorité et vous aimez la dominer
sur nous tous la personne a le choix
[Musique]
ici elle choisit l'obéissance consciente  ess
libération vie
vous